speaking of the same people doing the
same thing can we put up the warning we
have to show you it's a short clip from
The View it's just a short one today
it's Anna Navarro she doesn't like the
santis either and uh take a look
I I just gotta respond to Ron DeSantis
who said what's really bad is one
faction weaponizing government against a
faction it doesn't like Ronnie you mean
like you're doing to Disney Mickey Mouse
and drag queens
look in the mirror you hypocrite
oh and uh you are a hypocrite you used
to be a roughly sane conservative you
worked for Marco Rubio you were either
his campaign manager or PR person or
whatever it was you live in Florida you
live in Florida as I keep noting she
lives somewhere near me okay like I'm
going to see her at a restaurant it's
gonna be nasty when when it happens
um yes okay we don't have to go into the
Disney thing you get why the sadness did
the Disney thing and he took away
special rights and all that so that's
Disney and Mickey Mouse they're just
absolute Liars by the way Brock just
brought up a great point where we were
showing you the clip last week we were
showing you videos about how mainstream
media was going after Ron DeSantis
because he's friends with Clarence
Thomas so on one hand he's friends with
a guy who happens to be black who's a
brilliant legal mind that's a problem
then on the other hand he's also grand
wizard of the KKK and while I am certain
that the current Grand wizard I'm sorry
excuse me governor of my home state of
Florida
every direction that they can spin you
and they will spin you and that's also
why lefties and these NPC these
non-playable character people it's why
they're so angry all the time it's why
they're not funny it's why they never
smile it's why they're miserable
[Music]
foreign